[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Nicolas dandri
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde on commence
avec une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
voyageurs du tramway T13 effectivement
la circulation de nuit du tram 13 ne
sera pas rétabl les perturbations qui
devaient s'interrompre à la fin du mois
de février se poursuivront jusqu'à la
fin de l'année 2024 en cause les travaux
sur la ligne T13 et sur la ligne L pour
mener à bien les aménagements les
ouvriers sont contraints de couper le
courant des lignes en entre saintclou et
Saint-Non la Bretèche impactant ainsi le
parcours du tram des bus de substitution
le remplaceront en semaine de 21h à
minuit on poursuit avec l'inquiétude de
quatre maires de Saint-Quentin en
iveline ils sont préoccupés par la
possible installation du stade du PSG
sur l'île de loisir de Sky quatre maires
de gauche les maires de coignère
maniléameau guillancour et trappe les
quatre élus pointent du doigt le manque
de communication sur les négociations
entre le Qatar propriétaire du club de
foot actuel leader de Ligue 1 et et les
présidents de la région Île-de-France et
de l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Éveline depuis plus d'un an il voit d'un
mauvais œil les conséquences néfastes
que le pojet le projet pourrait avoir
sur l'environnement puisque le stade
devrait être construit sur 50 hactares
espace naturel utilisé pour
l'agriculture locale et qui est qui est
notamment classé Natura 2000 nos
confrères de 7 h actu ont reçu le
communiqué des mares et il cite un autre
argument avancé par ses maires que le
Qatar est l'un des pires alliés disons
des groupes terroristes euh on parle du
Proche et Moyen-Orient bien évidemment à
l'inverse hein selon Jean-Michel
Fourgous le président de Saint-Quentin
en Yveline et bien ce projet pourrait
déclencher un bon économique booster
encore plus l'attractivité à la fois
économique et médiatique de
l'agglomération de 50 ans nibl on
continue avec les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 à quelques
mois l'heure était à la préparation pour
le vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin
en et oui aujourd'hui au Vélodrome
national de 51 en livline et bien la
Fédération française de cyclisme a
présenté au médias les différents
ateliers testés par les athlètes en vue
des Jeux olympiques de 2024 cet
après-midi un entraînement en altitude
avait notamment lieu le but était de
tester les les sportifs en fait de
tester une simulation à travers un
système de simulation un exercice à plus
de 3500 m d'altitude et les courageux de
la rédaction Nicolas pardon ça c'est moi
Michel midoro ja de dixmud et Castille
cocuin ont recueilli les réactions par
rapport à ce test lorsque vous êtes
capable de réaliser on va dire des
efforts à très haute intensité dans un
environnement stressant comme dans dans
un environnement hypoxique quand vous
revenez ensuite à une altitude comme
comme ici à Saint-Quentin vous avez
quelque part un avantage physiologique
parce que les les contraintes sont
inférieures et votre organisme va
pouvoir développer davantage davantage
de puissance lors de la compétition on
fait des stages sur plusieurs jours donc
une quinzaine ou vingtaine de jours et
en fin compte après ça quand on revient
en normoxi bah on sent en fait ça dépend
comment on réagit mais soit on se sent
bien dès le début ou soit ça vient de
semaines plus tard et à quelques mois
desgo on le disait l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline a décidé de
mettre le sport au cœur de ses projets
pour l'année 2024 effectivement et le
nom de l'appel à projet et bien c'est en
route vers les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 ça a été lancé par
l'agglomération en juin dernier sport
hardart du cirque ou encore dicté les
Tinois pourront bénéficier toute l'année
de ces animations les activités
proposées issues des 34 associations des
communes de cqutin en ieline seront
subventionnées à hauteur de 329000 €
elles seront accessibles pour les hommes
les femmes et les personnes en situation
de handicap bien merci beaucoup Nicolas
d'andr pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une actualité qui
vous fait réagir N n'hésitez pas à nous
la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag news